okay good afternoon everyone my name is
naraine murthy i'm a professor at uc
berkeley in bioengineering it's a
pleasure to be here my lab focuses on
drug delivery and molecular imaging
and the topic the title of my time my of
my talk today is therapeutic gene
editing enabled by new delivery vehicles
so cas9 based therapeutics have the
potential to revolutionize the treatment
of genetic diseases because of their
ability to correct disease-causing dna
mutations
and have the potential to treat a
variety of genetic diseases such as
cystic fibrosis and duchenne's muscular
dystrophy however
converting cas9 into a therapeutic
requires delivering it into cells and
this is challenging because of its large
size
in addition some cas9 gene editing
applications
require performing homology directed dna
repair and that even requires delivering
a donor dna
so there's therefore great interest in
being able to develop strategies for
delivering cas9 into cells and in vivo
a variety of methods have already been
developed to do this these can be
broken down into two broad categories
those based upon viral vectors shown on
the left here and those based upon
non-viral vectors each one of these has
their own pros and cons which i'll
describe on the next slide
viral based methods for delivering
casting are by far the most efficient
ways of transducing cas9 into cells and
cells and in vivo
of the viral based methods aav is
perhaps the most advanced there's
already been a human clinical trial with
aav
cast9 gene editing in the eye
however using aav or other viruses to
deliver cas9 can be problematic
and this is because these viruses have
really been designed to deliver human
genes into people for human gene therapy
where the idea is that you want the
human gene to be replaced for a long
period of time
that however is a problem in the case of
gene editing and this is because gene
editing enzymes are invariably bacterial
enzymes and will cause an immune
response if they are expressed in people
for long periods of time
so the problem with using aav for
example for gene editing is that the the
delivered cas9 will be expressed in
cells for at least about four to five
years and this causes two problems first
because it's a foreign protein our
immune system will recognize that their
cells are expressing foreign proteins
and these cells will be targeted for
mhc-1 mediated dna damage
in addition
having a continued expression of cas9
can be problematic because of the
potential for off-target dna damage
uh cas9 does have a have a about a one
to two percent off target dna damage
rate and if you express it for long
periods of time such as five years uh
the the probability that you'll just
that you will generate genetic mutations
in cells is quite high
so there is therefore great interest in
developing non-viral strategies to
deliver cas9 the big rationale for
delivering cas9 non-virally is that gene
editing is permanent once you have done
the genetic modification in a cell you
don't need the cas9 to be in that cell
anymore because the edited cells will
have a permanent modification to them so
non-viral delivery is ideal for that
because if you deliver cas9 via plasmid
messenger rna or protein
all those
all those modalities will get degraded
in cells on the time scale of about 48
hours and that's enough time for the
cas9 to do its editing and then it's
gone so that that that solves two
problems first it dramatically lowers
the probability of an mhc-1 mediated
immune response and two it also
dramatically lowers the potential for
off-target dna damage so there's
therefore great interest in being able
to develop strategies to deliver cas9
non-virally into cells this is actually
quite challenging and in general
non-viral delivery strategies are lower
in efficiency than viral delivery
strategies however there is one
exception here which is the liver in the
liver uh intelia already had a
successful clinical trial in the liver
where they were able to deliver cas9 as
messenger rna and get editing in humans
with very high efficiency
so this is a major landmark uh and uh
and so in the liver i think non-viral
editing is possible for therapeutic
applications uh but outside of the liver
which is where the majority of genetic
diseases actually are
it's still an unsolved problem
so to address this this problem our lab
developed
a delivery vector called crispr gold
this was done in 2017
and crispr gold is a nanoparticle
technology that's designed to deliver
cas9 protein guide rna and also donor
dna and
correct genes in cells via homology
directed dna repair uh crispr gold the
rationale for crispr gold is that it's a
nanoparticle that has all the components
needed to do homology directed dna
repair
and uh can and so that every cell that
takes up a crispr gold nanoparticle will
then
undergo hdr efficiently
i should mention that this this uh this
work was done in collaboration with
multiple laboratories including
irena convoys lab who's at the uc
berkeley jacob corn who's now at the
etihad in switzerland uh jennifer
doudna's laboratory who's at uc berkeley
and also kazunori kataoku's lab who's at
the university of tokyo
the way crispr gold is synthesized is we
take a dna molecule and conjugate it to
a gold nanoparticle
and
we then take advantage of the fact that
the cas9 rnp has affinity for
double-stranded dna and we can just take
our our dna conjugated gold and mix it
with the cas9 rnp the cas9 rnp binds the
gold and we can centrifuge that and
purify it extensively we then take that
complex and mix it with an endosomal
disruptive polymer called psdt and that
is what gives us crispr gold
there are a wide variety of genetic
diseases that we can potentially treat
with crispr gold we selected duchenne's
muscular dystrophy as an initial target
and this is because of the tremendous
unmet medical need with regards to
treating duchenne's muscular dystrophy
so duchenne's is a genetic disease that
affects caucasian males has a high
frequency of about one in three thousand
five hundred there's no cure for this
disease and everybody who has this
disease dies in their 40s or 30s
duchenne's muscular dystrophy is caused
by a mutation in the dystrophin gene
dystrophin is shown on this slide here
and it is needed for maintaining muscle
health and the reason you need
dystrophin in muscle tissue is because
our muscle cells are constantly getting
stretched because of the of their
contraction cycles and that stretching
uh imposes a lot of physical damage on
them and dystrophin is basically there
to protect them from the stretching
cycles the stretching and contraction
cycles that muscle tissue undergoes
repeatedly
so in people who suffer from duchenes
they don't make dystrophin and their
muscle tissue starts to die off and that
eventually leads to death
now now uh crispr-based therapeutics
have the potential to treat duchenne's
muscular dystrophy by by cutting the
dystrophin gene at the site of its
mutation and correcting it via homology
directed dna repair so it has tremendous
potential for treating duchene's
muscular dystrophy
so we investigated
if crispr gold could rescue mice
suffering from duchene's muscular
dystrophy via the triggering of homology
directed dna repair so what we did is we
made crispr gold that had a cast 9
that was designed to cut the dystrophin
mutation and also a donor dna that was
designed to correct it this was done in
collaboration with irena convoy's lab
and then for these experiments we used
the mdx mouse model the mdx mouse model
is a mouse that has a mutation in the
dystrophin gene and exon 21. it's a c to
t mutation that generates a stop codon
and so mdx mice do not make dystrophin
so we injected these mice in their
muscle tissue with with crispr gold
designed to correct this mutation by hdr
and after two weeks we we sacrificed
these mice and sequenced them to see if
we were correcting the dystrophin
mutation the results are shown here
the y-axis is the hdr efficiency
measured by deep sequencing the x-axis
is the two groups what you can see is
that if you inject these mice in their
muscle tissue with crispr gold
we're getting up to about a 5.4
correction efficiency so 5.4 of the
genomic dna isolated in the muscle
tissue near the vicinity of the
injection had been corrected back to the
wild type sequence and in the control it
was around zero
5.4 is a fairly high it's a fairly is a
reasonable editing rate uh that's that's
speculated to be where you would start
seeing clinical benefits in the case of
duchene's
we also analyze these mice for uh
for the expression of dystrophin protein
all the way on the right here is a
histology slide of a wild type mouse
that has been stained with a dystrophin
antibody you can see that there's a lot
of disrobin dystrophin staining all the
way on the left is the control mdx mouse
uh if you stand with the dystrophin
antibody there is no standing as you
would expect they don't make dystrophin
however in the crease in the case of mdx
mice treated with crispr gold you can
see that there are regions where you
have very high dystrophin positivity and
so it can be as high as 60 percent
demonstrating that we are uh inducing
the re-expression of the dystrophin
protein
uh based on these studies uh the lead
author of this work his name was kunwu
lee
he was a graduate student in my lab he
formed a company called gen edit
which is now focused on developing
crispr gold and other cas9 delivery
vehicles and ultimately wants to bring
these type of technologies into clinical
trials uh what i'll talk about on the
next few slides is a collaboration
between our lab and genetic and another
lab uh at the university of texas and
san antonio in particular professor hey
young lee's lab
there are new there are numerous organs
where gene editing can have therapeutic
effects
of these the brain is perhaps one of the
most interesting
and this is because neurological
diseases such as huntington's and
alzheimer's affect millions of people
each year their incidence is
dramatically increasing because of the
aging population
and it turns out that it's actually
quite challenging to develop
therapeutics for brain diseases and this
is for many reasons one of them being
the blood-brain barrier and the other
one is the toxic effects of globally
inhibiting neuronal signaling pathways
we think that gene editing accomplished
by a local intracranial injection has
tremendous potential for treating brain
diseases and this is because if you do a
local intracranial injection you will
overcome the problems with the
blood-brain barrier
uh you will also just get local editing
and that should uh mitigate some of the
toxic side effects of brain therapeutics
and finally because gene editing is
permanent you'll only have to do this
once and doing intracranial injections
is already routinely done in a variety
of clinical scenarios such as for
treating epilepsy however despite its
potential very little is known about
brain gene editing
so to learn something about brain gene
editing we started a collaboration with
with gen edit and professor hey young
lee's lab at the university of texas in
san antonio
and we shipped them crispr gold that was
designed to do gene editing in the brain
and they investigated it in a mouse
model called the ai9 mouse model so the
ai9 mouse model is shown here it's
composed of a mouse that has the td
tomato gene
upstream of a stop codon integrated in
every one of its cells so these mice do
not make the td tomato gene which is the
same thing as the red fluorescent
protein
because of the stop codon however if you
cut out the stop signal by a crisper you
can then get the re-expression of the td
tomato gene which you can then easily
measure via fluorescence
so we made crispr gold that was designed
to cut out the stop codon
and shipped it to hey young's lab she
injected it into the striatum and
hippocampus and we've made two flavors
of crispr gold for this experiment one
that had cas9 and the other one that had
the gene editing enzyme cpf1
so the results of this experiment are
shown here which you can see on the top
section is those are the cas9 injected
mice
below that is the cpf1 injected mice so
the mice that were injected with cas9
have a lot of little red dots each one
of those red dots in the yellow square
is a cell that got two cuts
and uh had the re-expression of the td
tomato gene and so in both cases uh cas9
or cpf1 the amount of red dots is much
higher than in the control which really
has no red dots and
this demonstrates that we are able to
see some editing uh after an
intracranial injection of cas9 or cpf1
complex to crispr gold and that it's
actually reasonably efficient we were
able to get a number on this and it's
around 10 to 15 percent it's worth
mentioning that this is a fairly
challenging edit to do because you need
to make two cuts and then the gene has
to recombine cast iron is really good at
cutting but it's not particularly good
at doing recombination
so we therefore investigated if crispr
gold could do editing in neurons
specifically and to investigate this we
used um a mouse model where yfp or the
yellow fluorescent protein is only
expressed in neurons and we made crispr
gold that was designed to knock it out
by nhej
so we made crispr gold that was designed
to knock out the yfp gene we shipped it
to hey young's lab she injects it into
the hippocampus and then counts four yfp
negative cells the results are shown on
the slide here and again we made two
flavors one that has cas9 and the other
one that has cpf1
the y-axis here is the percent of yfp
cells on a histology slide the x-axis
is
the various groups and what you can see
is that
in the case of control
uh control mice about 30 of the cells or
neurons on a histology slide that
dramatically decreases all the way down
to about 10 percent uh with crispr gold
that either has cast iron or cpf1 uh
demonstrating that cas9 and or cpf1
complex to crispr gold can fairly
efficiently knock out genes uh after an
intracranial injection we're getting
knockout rates of around 50 percent
based on this we investigated if we
could um
if we could if crispr gold could
generate therapeutic effects in the
brain uh by by intracranial gene editing
and we selected fragile x-related autism
as an initial disease target
we selected this these this disease
because of the high unmet medical need
fragile x-related autism is the most
common hereditary form of autism it's
caused by a triplet repeat expansion in
the fmr1 gene that has the effect of
knocking out the fm1 gene
the fm01 gene is a is a global inhibitor
of protein expression and it turns out
that if you knock it out by this triple
triplet repeat expansion
you get a variety of pathologies in
terms of learning and development
it's also known that
the m glue r5
it's also known that the mglu r5
signaling pathway also is is
is over activated uh in patients who
suffer from fragile x-related autism
and so we investigated if we could treat
fragile x-related autism by knocking out
mglu r5
in um in a
mouse model for fragile x-ray related
autism which is composed of a fmr1
knockout mouse
so we made crispr gold that was designed
to knock out the m glue r5 gene
sent it to hay young's lab and she
injected it into fmr1 knockout mice or
wild-type mice and then looked for the
knockdown of mlura5 via
immunohistochemistry on histology slides
so the results are shown here
the y-axis is the number of m-glu r5
positive cells and the x-axis is the
various groups
so you can see that in both control
uh
in both wild type and fm1 knockout mice
the number of mglu r5 positive cells
dramatically decreases uh after
treatment with crispr gold so in the
case of wild type in the case of the
wild type mice it goes from 60
down to about 35 percent and the you see
similar numbers in the fm1 knockout mice
so this demonstrates that we can fairly
efficiently knock out mglu r5 after an
intracranial injection of crispr gold
so based on this we did a variety of
behavioral studies to see if uh crispr
gold could protect mice or rescue mice
from the repetitive behaviors that are
observed with autism and it turns out
that the effermon knockout mice uh
exhibits many of these obsessive
phenotypes one of them is that they jump
up and down obsessively in a cage and so
we investigated if and
and so not only do they jump up and down
obsessively in a cage it's also known
that this phenotype is caused by the
striatum
and so we investigated if knocking out
mlr5 in the striatum can rescue mice
from this phenotype
the results of this experiment are shown
here the y-axis is the number of jumps
in a cage the x-axis is the various
groups so you can see that f number one
knockout mice uh jump up and down much
more than the control mice so fmr1
knockout must jump up and down about 20
times in this experiment
whereas the control mice there's almost
no jump so there's a dramatic increase
in the jumping behavior of these mice
and that jumping behavior is decreased
um more than
more than about fourfold by partially
knocking out m glue r5 in the striatum
that's the m glue r5 crisper
bar
versus the control bar the black versus
the gray
there we also investigated some other
phenotypes such as line crossing which
have nothing to do nothing to do with
the stridom
line crossing is a phenotype that comes
from the hippocampus and in that case we
didn't actually see any effect as we
would expect given the fact that our
editing is only in the stride
all right i'm now going to talk about
another uh cas9 delivery strategy uh
that's focused on making cas9 protein
conjugates everything i've talked about
up to now is based upon making
have all been nanoparticle-based
delivery vehicles for cast nine
uh however nanoparticles have certain
limitations in particular they're big
crispr gold in particular is around 200
nanometers uh the large size of crispr
gold means that there'll be a lot of
tissues that it will not be able to
access
we're therefore very interested in being
able to make cas9
cas9 conjugates with polymers or
peptides that can do the delivery
by itself because that should be much
much smaller however
conjugating things to cast nine is
problematic because if you modify the
lysine residues of cas9 you will almost
certainly inactivate it to get around
this problem we developed a new linker
called the dec linker
which is a disulfide self-immolative
linker shown on this slide here the dec
linker is a combination of two linkers
shown on the top here where where it
says vector
dec protein and the dec linker is
composed of two uh linkers a thio ethyl
carbonate linker combined with the 1 6
elimination linker
which is then modifies which which then
modifies the lysine residue of your
protein
so this allows you to conjugate things
to proteins however in the presence of
glutathione or thiols present in the
cell
what ends up happening is the disulfide
bond is broken and that triggers two
cascade reactions two self-immolative
reactions which end up
completely releasing the protein without
any any tag or any modification of the
lysine residues
the dec linker has numerous applications
for protein delivery uh we've used it
for three different applications i'll
talk about two of them today
the first one that we'll talk about is
is
using it to enhance the diffusion of
proteins in brain tissue and this is
accomplished by a protein percolation so
this so using the dec linker we've been
able to conjugate peg to cast nine and
uh maintain the activity of cas9 and
also improve its diffusion through brain
tissue
in addition we've been able to conjugate
self-penetrating peptides to cast iron
and get self-delivering cast ions that
are also enzymatically active
and finally uh an application i won't
talk about is that we've also been able
to conjugate donor dna to to cas9 and
can improve the the ratio the rate of
hdr uh using again the dec linker
so so now i'm going to talk about
using the dec linker to conjugate peg to
cast 9. so we made a reagent that's
composed of peg conjugated to the dec
linker with a nitrophenyl group on there
and that allows us to stick peg onto
proteins in one step
there's a lot of interest in being able
to conjugate peg to proteins because it
reduces immunogenicity
and can increase circulation half-lives
and can also
improve tissue diffusion
through mucus and also brain tissue
however if you just conjugate peg
randomly to the lysine residues of a
protein you will almost certainly
inactivate it and hence the rationale
for the dec linker so the scheme shown
here explains how we're doing this so we
have the native cas9 with all its lysine
residues cast 9 has many lysine residues
we then mix it with the peg dec linker
which is called peg disulfide linker
that
sticks the peg groups randomly all over
the cast 9
and that basically generates a cas9 peg
conjugate that's going to be inactive
however once the cast ion goes inside of
the cell and there's glutathione uh the
the um
the the peg comes off and it comes off
completely and there's no residual
modification of lysine residue so you
get back your original casing which
should then be enzymatically active
so we started a collaboration with ross
wilson's laboratory at uc berkeley and
also chris benkowitz's lab at
the university of ohio
and
we investigated if
conjugating peg to cas9 can improve its
diffusion through tissue
so we shipped cas9 peg
conjugated through the dec linker to the
bankwitz lab
and they injected it into the stridom of
mice using a technique called convection
enhanced delivery and this is a
procedure where you can inject up to
seven microliters into them
into the striatum of a mouse and then uh
immediately after doing the injection uh
they sacrificed the mice and looked for
the presence of the cas9 via
immunohistochemistry so they stained
with an antibody the control for this
experiment was just an injection of the
same amount of cas9
so you can see on the right hemisphere
is what the immunohistochemistry of the
mouse looks like after injection with
cast 9 dec peg and the left is
uh what it looks like after injection
with cast nine so you can see and the
brown here is where the cast iron is so
you can see that in the in the in the
hemisphere that was injected with cas9
peg
uh there's brown staining all throughout
the striatum and that's suggesting that
the cast 9 is really diffusing quite
freely through the brain tissue given
that this is a
specific staining with an antibody and
that is
in stark contrast to what it looks like
uh after you um if you just inject the
native cas9
that seems to get stuck in the brain
tissue not surprising the the brain
tissue is very sticky so this
demonstrates that we can improve the
tissue diffusion of casting by
conjugating peg to it via the dec linker
we've also been able to conjugate cell
penetrating peptides to cast 9
using the dec linker to do this we made
this compound shown here
uh which is com which which we're
calling cppdc and that's composed of the
cell penetrating peptide
nine arginine nine so nine arginines and
it's now conjugated to a fluorescent dye
so we can easily
we can easily track it and then it also
has been it also has another functional
handle on there which is this
nitrophenyl group conjugated to the
arginine via a disulfide linkage so the
nitrophenyl group here is what actually
does the conjugation to the protein
it'll react with the lysine residues on
the protein and then once in the
presence of thiols everything comes off
and you get the the traceless release of
the protein so that's what's shown on
the bottom here
the way we do the chemistry is we take
the cas9 uh
which is which is shown on the left
native cast 9 we mix it with cpp dec
that randomly conjugates to all the
lysine residues on the protein again
generating what's most likely an
inactive protein but then once it
reaches the cytoplasm all of the cpps
come off because of the disulfide
reduction and you get the unmodified
protein which should be enzymatically
active
so we actually investigated if
this is actually so so what we did was
we made cas9 cpp by doing the chemistry
i just showed you uh where we had about
40 cpps per cast 9 and then we
investigated its activity before and
after reduction with glutathione and
this is five millimolar glutathione
so the on the left you can see the gel
uh where we investigated the enzymatic
activity of cast iron cpp where it was
mixed with the guide rna uh
where it was mixed with the donor where
it was mixed with template dna uh that
was specific for the guide rna and on
the right of that is um
is the
the quantitation of this gel so the
y-axis is nuclease activity and the
x-axis is the various groups and what
you can see here is that cas9 cpp so if
you have the cpps conjugated to the cas9
it is actually almost completely
inactive not surprising given the that
there are a lot of lysine residues on
cas9 that are essential however if you
now reduce the the cpp off you can
almost get a hundred percent activity
back and there's no difference between
the cas9 cpp plus gsh and the wild type
cas9 demonstrating that the linker
really is traceless and it's it's not
leaving any tag on there and that we can
recover the protein activity
finally we did investigate if cas9 cpp
could edit
cells
so in this experiment we took cas9 cpp
that had a guide rna that targets the
gfp gene and we incubated it with
hex cells that express gfp
and uh
and then after um 48 hours we isolated
these cells and sent them for sanger
sequencing so the results are shown here
the y-axis is the editing efficiency and
the x-axis is the various groups so the
the green bar is a control where if you
just take cas9 rnp and add it to cells
you only see about 0.3 percent of
editing is determined by sanger
sequencing again almost the background
levels and that increases all the way up
to 5.1 percent if you conjugate uh
arginine 9 as a cpp to the cast 9
via the dec linker so we saw a big
enhancement in the amount of editing uh
more than a 10-fold almost a 20-fold
increase in editing over the wild-type
cast 9 and at least in this experiment
this is comparable this is comparable to
life effectively so we're now in the
process of of optimizing this and and
finding other
ways of improving the delivery
efficiency of uh cas9 conjugates
so in summary i've talked about two
different methodologies for delivering
the cas9 the first one was was a
technology called crispr gold which was
uh able to do gene editing in muscle
tissue and also in the brain and finally
um the second technology i talked about
was the dec linker which allowed us to
make uh which allowed us to conjugate uh
peptides and polymers to cas9 and
in a reversible manner and also retain
the activity of the cas9
so i want to thank the people that did
the work um the
all the crispr gold work was done by one
very talented graduate student named
kunwuli who's now the ceo of genetic
and uh the dec linker was done by a
postdoc named mao mao he so finally
thank you thank you for your attendance